EVS get a bad reputation in cold weather
they're known for running out of range
super quickly they charge too slowly
Tesla heat pump is about changing all
those Notions and making an EV for all
kinds of weather
the biggest Innovation definitely for
our team is the heat pump system the
easiest way to think about a heat pump
is like an air conditioner in Reverse an
air conditioning system takes heat out
of your house and pumps it through the
outside environment which is hotter the
heat pump harvesting heat when it's cold
outside and pushing an engine to the
cabin of the car you know the basis of
it is just around like using the energy
you have to make the vehicle more
efficient it works together to pick the
source that makes sense given the
conditions that you're in but it can
also turn inward in really cold weather
where other heat pumps fall short it can
keep the cabin comfortable and generate
its own heat and prioritize power
we first introduced heat pump system in
modern y but now we have it on all
platforms 3s and X
so heat pumps are not A New Concept but
a lot of times when someone implements a
heat pump system they do that by adding
a lot of components and we wanted to
implement the benefits of a heat pump
system but at the same time reduce the
complexity so the idea we came up with
we're calling it The Super manifold and
it's basically a two layer PCB assembly
this section in the front is all of the
refrigerant channels that would normally
be separate components and separate
tubes while connecting things together
we did a similar thing with the coolant
components so we have a layer in the
back that's all of the coolant channels
all plumbed together this would normally
be 15 20 separate components in a car
and we've made it into one assembly
that's all together
in order to achieve the functionality of
the heat pump we needed a new
configuration for our coolant Loop so we
could have done that pretty easily just
by adding an additional valve but that
would have been more expensive and it
would have made the car harder to build
what if we tried to combine those two
valves into a single valve and that's
kind of how everyone thinks here doing
two things that are almost the same in
one case I'm throwing heat out and the
other case I'm adding heat in maybe I
should just put those together and have
system integration so this is the design
that we ended up with after many
convolutions I mean we call it the
octave valve and it's very simple it's
got a barrel inside that churns
depending on the mode we're activating
different pairs of ports depending on
the conditions the Energy Efficiency of
heating you might be using three or four
times less energy if you can carry a
bigger load more cargo more passengers
and you can still get to your
destination while consuming 15 to 20
less energy is significant and that is
something that's not quite apparent by
just looking at the car you really have
to experience it